yo it's crazy because like um
and when i was in high school and you
guys
kind of had that the first houston run
i want to say that was like oh 405
oh three
four five yeah even though three yeah
and uh
it felt very i remember there was like
the double xl cover or the source cover
don't mess with texas everybody was on
the cover slim thug signed a star track
like you you were doing your thing i
mean switcher house was a movement
um
there are so many artists now from
houston like when we think of travis
scott like travis scott's one of the
biggest artists in the world right and
he obviously bangs houston heavy astro
world all that right but like i feel
like
i don't know if it feels like there's
like a unison movement out of the city
with the newer artists do you feel cause
back then it felt like there was a real
movement the cohesiveness yeah
well um yeah i don't think it
necessarily is now when we came out
the movement was a little different
because there was the screwed up click
artist and the switch house artist and
it was a similar style of rap
where you know we had similar subject
matter similar type of slow down type of
beats of course you know switch house we
got the style from screw but being that
there was the screwed up all the artists
that were around at the time at our time
you know the switch house and screw clip
artist
we had us you know the movement was
there because we had a similar style we
had a similar fan base all of that
whereas now you got lizzo
uh normani
megan the stallion maxo cream toby new
wigway sauce walker
travis scott don toliver
where everyone's got their own vibe don
tyler chavis
from houston yeah dr oliver travis scott
got similar style but it's way different
than toby
and that's completely different than
sauce walker and that's so different
than normani or izzo you know so it's
you know it's it's d and there's not to
mention all of the other houston artists
that are like blowing up right now on
tick-tock or the non-traditional methods
that we came up that i don't even know
about yet but they popping and you know
getting 50 000 a show and i don't even
know them you know those artists out
there too where they building their fan
bases up
you know outside of the houston
you know market uh and i think that's a
little bit wide too where you know when
we came we
rep texas to the fullest well they also
do but when people played our music they
played it as a pride thing too they're
repping texas by playing on music
and you guys had a very unison
like sonic movement i feel like yeah
where it'd be like even if you listen to
like already platinum from slim thug
like right right even with pharrell
production you'd be like nah this is
some texas [ __ ] yeah exactly exactly but
they're all the artists there they still
rep h-town like you said for sure
they're not kind of known as being
h-town when you think of us you think oh
h-town texas you know 100